joining us with reaction senator john
kennedy of louisiana senator
first there was no mask mask was going
to work then it was one mask then two
masks and maybe masks in perpetuity then
he told us that if we got the vaccine we
would never contract covert well now
people that have the vaccine they have
two shots and they have two boosters and
they have previous infections well now
they're getting covered a second time so
they were wrong on the science but the
worst part to me is the lie and that is
don't we now know for a fact that nih
money taxpayer dollars went to fund this
wuhan virology lab and that they knew
gain and function research and
coronavirus research took place at that
facility
two points sean
number one as i think i have told you
before
i don't hate anyone and that includes dr
fauci he has
decided to retire in december and i wish
him well
however
and this is my second point
unless you do your research on twitter
you know that the american people have
many many questions
about how dr fauci other public health
officials and our government handle the
pandemic
and getting answers to those questions
from dr fauci and others
has been like trying to slam a revolving
door
now the democrats are in charge they
refuse
to press but the republicans will
so here's my prediction
if republicans take back one or both
houses of congress
and unless dr fauci retirement or not
decides to seek asylum
in some uh
some remote obscure foreign country
jackpot wuhan china will take them
well unless dr fauci decides to seek
asylum in some foreign country whose
powerball jackpot is 287 chickens and a
goat
and therefore which won't enforce a
subpoena from the united states congress
then dr fauci retirement or not is going
to be spending a lot of time
in front of a congressional committee
and committees if republicans take back
control we're going to ask him questions
about gain of function research
why he didn't push back on china's lies
why he pushed back so hard on the
possibility which we know is now real
that the virus originated in a chinese
lab
why he went along with the greatest
dissipation if that's the right word
greatest taking of civil liberties of
the american people in the history of
our country we're going to have a lot of
questions and and we're going to
subpoena him and expect him to answer
and i would not advise dr fauci to put
down a non-refundable deposit on a
cruise
well let me ask you this because we have
his emails in january of 2020 in a
flurry of emails
among other nih executives
that seemed to show great concern what
might be found out about monies going to
the wuhan virology lab then you have the
intercept 900 pages they revealed and
project veritas and then we have i
believe it was october of 2020
or 2021 the nih's own email show that
they knew about gain of function
research do you believe dr fauci
purposely
lied to the american people about what
he knew about the coronavirus about the
wuhan virology lab and about american
tax dollars funding gain of function
i don't know but we need to find out and
it's not about
republicans or democrats and it's not
about dr fauci
it's about the american people now
they've been through hell
in part on the advice of dr fauci maybe
he was right
but maybe he was wrong
and then and the last conversation i had
with dr fauci
with respect to whom i bear no ill will
he was in front of a committee they only
gave me five minutes
i asked him a simple question what did
we learn from the from the pandemic
and i got a femonious amount of bs
now the democrats won't press
but if we take back control of this
congress we will
and retirement or not he will be subject
to a congressional subpoena
and the american people deserve answers
they have been through hell and and to
say nothing of the fact that we may have
to go through this sometime again soon
we want to be ready
we better be ready well said senator
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else